[Musique]
non
bonsoir dans la tente du vaccin pour
tout le monde c'est le feuilleton qui ne
fait que commencer d'autant que les
variants pourrait remettre en cause les
campagnes de vaccination qui sont déjà
lancés les personnes âgées pour
l'instant sens prioritaire mais à plus
ou moins long terme il faudra peut-être
élargir la gamme des populations qui
sont autorisés à être vaccinés notamment
ceux qui sont mobilisés auprès des plus
fragiles je pense par exemple aux
bénévoles d'associations en tout cas la
solidarité plus que jamais à l'ordre du
jour depuis le début de la crise du
corner virus il ya un an maintenant et
ce soir dans audition publique le rendez
vous politique du lundi sur lcp public
sénat avec le figaro nous recevons
olivia grégoire bonsoir bonsoir les
secrétaires d'état à l'économie sociale
solidaire et responsable comme ça ça
fait bizarre c'est compliqué mais ça
représente beaucoup de monde pas tant
que ça c'est pas si compliqué c'est un
peu nouveau
on a connu d'un haut commissaire le ss
pendant trois ans il y avait auparavant
benoît hamon qui s'occupait de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
la petite nouveauté c'est que l'économie
sociale et solidaire s'est vu adjoindre
l'adjectif responsable ça élargit
effectivement on aura l'occasion mêlant
pour dire c'est pas ça va des
associations juste au scope par exemple
en passant par les cinq familles si vous
me donnez une seconde c'est vraiment une
seconde alors très chaud fallait plus
vite et ça représente des millions de
gens effectivement de les mutuelles les
associations principalement employeuse
les coopératives les fondations et les
entreprises d'utilité sociale alias et
zus et c'est beaucoup et de coups au
visage
on a beaucoup de questions à vous poser
d'ailleurs alors le ministre de la santé
votre collègue olivier brand s'est fait
vacciner ce matin mais il bénéficie de
son statut de praticien hospitalier pour
avoir droit à cette piqûre parce que
normalement les ministres n'ont pas à se
faire piquer avant les autres c'était
son métier d'origine avant d'entrer au
gouvernement
est-ce que vous pensez que ça c'est
utile ou c'est un peu vieilli
communication un peu propagande
or je vais vous répondre comme je suis
c'est à dire avec franchise
il ne fait pas on interroge il le fait
on interroge moi je pense que c'est bien
qu'il l'ait fait i les soignants
effectivement c'est un praticien
hospitalier et d'ailleurs jusqu'à ce
qu'ils soient ministres
une pratique est encore au chu de
grenoble est une pratique plus non mais
il est au contact au quotidien des
praticiens des malades dessus puisqu'il
se déplace
quasiment tous les jours donc je pense
que c'est aussi important en terme d'
exemple
était de démontrer que on y va avec la
mise à la santé n'a pas peur ce compte
là vous aussi vous êtes au contact de
shippagan j'en retiens espi terme et
vous êtes au contact de plein de gens
pourquoi ce serait scandaleux que tous
les ministres se fasse sans quoi ce
serait scandaleux
bah en fait je vais vous dire si cela
était lié on est dans une période où
tout est scandaleux et tout est
potentiellement polémique
moi je trouverai pas scandaleux que les
ministres notamment ceux qui sont au
quotidien en contact soit vaccinée en
attendant des gens comme moi qui sont
pas tous les jours dans les hôpitaux
mais en revanche au contact
d'associations de coopératives on
pratique les gestes barrières comme tous
les français je pense que c'est très
important de nos jours face à la
défiance politique qui nous gagne depuis
maintenant des décennies d'être aussi
exemplaire donc c'est cohérent que le
mythe de la santé qui est praticien
hospitalier comme les professionnels de
santé se fassent vacciner
il vous a pas échappé que je ne suis pas
en ehpad et que j'ai pas du tout récent
de cinq ans et donc on respecte aussi le
tempo et donc mon tour viendra mais je
pense le chic on prêterait le flanc à la
polémique
si prioritairement les 41 membres du
gouvernement le faisais et que les
français de 50 ans par exemple n'y avait
pas forcément tous accès dès aujourd'hui
pendant ce temps tout cas les médecins
scolaires où ils s'inquiètent parce
qu'ils préconisent d'allonger les
vacances de février et même de fermer
les écoles pendant quatre semaines à
votre
niveau de connaissance est ce que c'est
à l'étude à mon niveau de connaissance
le président a eu un une prise de parole
très clair la semaine dernière et à
cette heure j'ai pas eu d'information
notamment de jean michel blanc car par
exemple m'informant que ce rallongement
était en tout cas dans les tuyaux donc
j'ai pas plus d'informations que ça je
comprends en revanche leur inquiétude ça
faisait d'ailleurs en toute franchise
partie des idées qui volaient la semaine
dernière et qui tournait notamment dans
les médias ça n'a pas été la position
arrêtée par le gouvernement et à cette
heure elle n'est pas plus que la semaine
passée sur le plateau avec moi ce soir
comme tous les lundis soir de l'audition
publique brigitte boucher de lcp bonsoir
rigide pour certains si c'est un revenu
de public sénat bonsoir tape dans l'oeil
agrément sfar des américains il commence
on va continuer à parler vaccination il
ya une question qui se pose pour les
bénévoles dans les associations où il ya
beaucoup de bénévoles seniors qui ont
plus de 65 ans mais qui n'ont pas encore
75 ans est-ce que vous souhaiter qu'ils
soient prioritaires pour être vaccinés
j'ai eu une attention toute particulière
dès mon arrivée fin juillet pour
peut-être protéger plus est plus fort
les bénévoles
un exemple dès le mois d'août avec mon
équipe on a positionné deux millions de
masques dans les préfectures
ça n'a pas forcément été chu par
l'ensemble du grand public mais ça a été
connue des responsables associatifs
la moindre des choses était que l'état
met à leur disposition de quoi plus se
protéger pour pouvoir mieux accompagner
les autres j'ai aussi continuer on en
reparlera jouit pas 30 millions d'euros
pour les acteurs associatifs genre en
parler je sais je vous en remercie pas
pour moi mais pour eux l'objection le
vaccin sur l'étoile de la mort on se
protège pour les accents on est là aussi
cohérent on a un calendrier qui est
scandée qui est précis ça dépend des
tranches d'âge à cette heure il n'y a
pas de priorisation des bénévoles tout
âge que les seniors puissent être dans
les associations vacciner rapidement est
une priorité comme pour tous les plus de
65 mais il n'y a pas spécifiquement de
coups de fil
pour les bénévoles ce qu'il faut à vos
yeux que les seniors de plus de 75 ans
qui interviennent des associations
soient vaccinés je pense que c'est
important et ils sont dans le calendrier
c'est un mais ce qu'il faut qu'il le
soit est-ce que vous est-ce que ça doit
les faire partie de leurs engagements si
on va en parler de l'engagement mais je
suis dans le contrat d'engagement
savoure le coach ou d'autoriser là le
jeu de mots mais vous savez quand on est
bénévole
on donne déjà beaucoup aux autres et on
dit super responsable donc j'ai assez
confiance en eux pour qu'ils soient
responsables et quelqu'un qui ne
seraient pas vaccinés on lui dit pas tu
viens pas non c'est pas l'idée il ya
aussi des bénévoles d'associations
humanitaires qui raconte avoir été
verbalisé pour avoir été dans la rue
après 18h alors même qu'ils étaient en
train de travailler pour leur
association
est-ce que vous souhaitez que soit donné
des consignes claires pour que ces
bénévoles ne soit plus inquiétés alors
vous soulevez là un point important
j'étais jeudi et vendredi à marseille
j'ai d'ailleurs un quelqu'un qui m'a
interrompu dans la rue juste titre et
qui m'a posé cette question
j'en ai parlé avec le préfet et les
consignes claires ont été données je
pense notamment aux maraudes je crois
qu'on lui qui parlait dé du froid qui
nous attend il est très important que
les bénévoles qui donnent de leur temps
aux autres puissent avoir liberté grâce
aussi à leur attestation il bénéficie
détestation des associations pour
pouvoir poursuivre leur mission
d'intérêt général
donc c'est une consigne que nous avons
passé au préfet que j'ai repassé
vendredi
là où vous avez raison c'est que j'ai eu
connaissance du fait que certains
avaient été verbalisées la consigne a
été très clairement repasser dès que je
rentre et je fais passer le mot mystère
dans toutes les interviews et dans
toutes les préfectures mans les les
maraudes à la frontière italienne pour
les migrants un certain nombre
d'associations ont été énormément
verbaliser alors ça c'est normal
aide alimentaire oui quand on aide les
autres qu'on prend sur son temps et
qu'on a une attestation
je pense qu'on a pas être verbalisés est
ce que vous y voyez
mais est ce que il n'y avait pas aussi
quelque chose de politique a empêché les
maraudes l'envers les migrants à la
frontière franco italienne
je comprends votre question mais je ne
crois absolument pas que c était le cas
et encore une fois c'est pas parce qu a
eu quelques cas qui nous sont remontés
que c'est le cas dans l'ensemble de la
france il ya beaucoup d'associations de
nuit je pense à paris notamment qui
continue à travailler et qui s'apprête
d'ailleurs à travailler dans les
prochains jours il n'y a pas ce sujet là
et on a déjà échangé avec la préfecture
de police de paris
en prévention alors c'est un autre sujet
qu'il séparatisme le projet doit
séparatisme qui est débattue en ce
moment à l'assemblée il ya la charte des
valeurs républicaines sets à un article
a été voté vendredi dernier
est-ce que ça concerne toutes les
associations c'est à dire celles qui
existent déjà comme celles qui vont être
nouvellement créé la charte concerne
comme d'ailleurs ce qu'on fait au plan
économique concerne à la fois celles qui
sont créés et celles qui sont
nouvellement créée est en cours de
création et est ce que il faudra enfin
est ce que vous croyez que cette charte
elle suffira pas ce qu'on peut très bien
signer la charte et puis continuer ses
activités il y aura plus de contrôle
écoutez il ya ces mêmes au coeur de ce
qui a été voté la semaine passée autour
du conte 32 contrats d'engagement
c'est plus qu'une charte le contrat
d'engagement pour le coup c'est un
engagement dans le droit dur et donc
j'ai bon espoir que ce soit respectée on
s'est pas mal fait critiquer d'ailleurs
sur ce sujet du contrat d'engagement
comporte avec avec force et je pense que
comme tout contrat les associations de
respecteront le cas échéant elles
s'exposeront et elles le savent
soit à des sanctions soit une possible
fermeture le yale daily de séparatisme
ci qui a été votée est ce que ça peut
concerner les associations qui
refuserait de signer la charte justement
branche d'aplatir vous pensent et pour
ça en tout cas c'est l'objectif mais
c'est ce que je
jeudi sur le contrat d'engagement ça va
faire des contraintes supplémentaires
pour les associations est ce que vous
pensez que ça peut freiner la liberté
d'association est ce que ça peut en tout
cas freiner les bonnes volontés ne crois
pas alors après moi j'ai change tout le
temps avec le mouvement associatif dont
j'ai la charge sur notamment le plan
économique
je comprends qu'ils aient des
discussions et qu'ils aient eu pas mal
d'échangés j'en ai fait partie et je
veux dire avec force qui a en rien une
défiance n'est pas du tout dans une
posture de défiance après je comprends
et on en a beaucoup parlé avec le
président notamment du mouvement
associatif qui j'échange toutes les
semaines
comment qu'il est très important que les
associations soient vraiment associer
pardonnez-moi la tautologie les furets à
ce alors rassurés on y travaille elles l
ont elles savent celui que je vais faire
une analogie c'est un peu comme le
portique dans les aéroports c'est
compliqué de se dire qu'on doit tous
quelque part être un peu contrôlées dans
l'univers associatif sous prétexte que
très peu en réalité mais certaines ne
respecte pas le principe républicain
je comprends qu'on puisse pas s'émouvoir
mais se questionner sur le fait que tous
soient interrogés tout soit interrogé
sous prétexte que quelques unes ne
respectent pas le pacte républicain mais
vous savez comme toujours avec les
associations s'ils ont ce qu'on se pose
calmement et qu'on donne la réalité des
fondements de la loi
on arrive à échanger tout l'enjeu
maintenant pour moi c'est les décrets
qui arrive tout l'enjeu c'est comment ce
contrat d'engagement va être appliquée
vraiment et ça c'est vous savez bien ici
ce sont les décrets d'application et
j'ai demandé je redis avec force je
trouve très important pour pas dire
fondamental que les associations soient
très directement associés à la rédaction
du décret d'application qui vont aussi
les concernés citerai un portrait
tournoi pour une minorité l'a finalement
c'est exactement ce que je viens de vous
dire j'admets mois sans sans problème
que sous prétexte que certaines posent
problème
nous contrôlions plus les autres vous
m'accorderez aussi brigitte boucher que
on nous a beaucoup reproché la naïveté
depuis quelques années et même bien
avant nous sur ce sujet des associations
on prend le sujet à bras le corps il
s'agit pas de défiance il s'agit pas non
plus d'être naïf on vous dit
conem beaucoup d'associations qui vont
le signer sans aucun problème quand vous
dites on va avant de passer la parole à
tam que les associations vont être
associés au décret ça va se passer
comment un grenelle n'ont pas de
grenelle on est là sur un décret ça se
passera comment ça se passera que il
faut qu'on bosse ensemble ministère de
l'intérieur avait tout est réuni moi je
suis à bercy il vous a pas échappé que
je porte pas le texte
au fond c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur c'est marlène schiappa qui
le porte
en deuxième ligne évidemment un gérald
darmanin c'est donc au ministère de
l'intérieur et j'ai demandé déjà
plusieurs fois et je crois avoir été
entendu qu'elles soient associés à la
rédaction très concrètement du décret
d'application comment s'applique ce
texte qui va les concerner est ce qu'il
ya des associations que vous soupçonnez
de prosélytisme aujourd'hui alors est-ce
que je soupçonne moi vous savez je suis
ministre
le gouvernement est ce que le
gouvernement avait affronté cette montée
sur une quantité d'associations tu crois
qu'on a dit on a même d'ailleurs
démontré que certaines en faisait montre
puisque un certain d'associations de
forme associative ont été dissoutes
concernés c'est quoi l'un versé sous
prétexte que ça ne concerne qu'une
poignée il faudrait rien faire non non
c'est ce que vous avez des chiffres
est-ce que vous avez une région n'est
pas je suis encore une fois je suis
secrétaire d'état à bercy je les ai pas
je pense qu'à l'intérieur et peut-être
aux renseignements généraux je m'en
doute pas ils en ont est-ce que vous
travaillez puisque vous avez parlé
effectivement de ces associations qui
ont été dissoutes à la dissolution
d'autres associations aujourd'hui
l'association précise moi je c'est
toujours un plaisir et c'est vrai que
j'ai été porte parole mais je peux pas
lire dans le marc de café des prochaines
actions de gérald darmanin à 7 heures
pour être très précise il n'est pas
prévu par exemple la semaine prochaine
ou même cette semaine je crois d'autres
dissolution au sein du conseil des
ministres mais soyons clairs vous savez
mon chum il est depuis six mois à peine
je découvre l'ordre du jour du conseil
des ministres quand j'arrive dans le
bunker à bercy et quand en tant que
secrétaire d'état si je suis convié ce
qui n'est pas automatique donc très
bonne question mais j'aimerais bien vous
répondre mais c'est gérald a préparé une
sur bercy une question qui peut vous
intéresser sur baraka city notamment
parce que oui c'est ce qu'ils
travaillent à l'étranger si vous voulez
voilà c'est une ong humanitaire proche
des islamistes qui a été dissoute par
gérald darmanin
elle annonce vouloir s'installer à
l'étranger mais veut continuer en même
temps ses activités en france
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'en empêcher
et qu'est ce qu'il ya dans la loi qu'est
ce que prévoit la loi pour ce cas là par
exemple on peut les en empêcher déjà
écouté déjà en les à dissoudre dont va
falloir que s'ils tentaient qu'elle se
recréer qu'elle trouve une formulation
qui ne soit pas associatif puisque ce
type d'association au jamais peuvent
avoir leur siège à l'extérieur alors
continuez déjà leurs activités mais vous
savez et bruno le maire est l idée du
soft
il travaille beaucoup on a aussi des
services de renseignement économique et
financier qui te permettre de traquer
sans mauvais jeu de mots les flux
financiers douteux et nous sommes en
plaques et donc nous observerons de très
près il s'agit pas de montant forcément
important c'est là qu'elles sont très
dangereux je pris publiquement à baraka
city s'est souvent des transactions de
quelques centaines d'euros mais qui
mises bout à bout arrive à démontrer
qu'il ya une activité sociale c'est là
que vous verrez si vous devez intervenir
ou pas mais c'est là qu'on se bat et ça
a été dit et redit mais par un euro et
en tout cas pas pas de flux oui tout ce
qui est nécessaire en tout cas il ya un
autre volet à cette loi sur le
séparatisme je l'appelle comme ça pour
faire simple brigitte ses volets social
oui c'est ça y'a 15 députés de la
majorité qui ont écrit au premier
ministre car il s'inquiète qu'il n'y a
pas de voler pour lutter contre les
inégalités sociales
est ce que vous vous êtes au moins en
partie d'accord avec eux alors je vais
peut-être vous surprendre je
tout ça très intéressant pour pas dire
très intelligent j'ai été trois ans et
demi députés à leurs côtés on n'était
pas toujours d'accord par exemple avec
pierre persan avec mireille clapot qui
aussi a signé ce texte c'est souvent
coralie du boss la présidente déléguée
moi je pense que c'est toujours
intéressant de se faire pousser plus
loin sur ces sujets même si je trouve
intéressant de reconnaître si ce qu'a
fait le gouvernement et je trouve que il
est important de le rappeler est pas que
depuis la crise duquel vide je vous
évite la liste aujourd'hui j'aurai
plaisir à un jour à revenir en parler ce
que je trouve intéressant c'est que
d'abord ils sont complètement dans leur
rôle c'est ce qu'on attend des
parlementaires qui sera force de
proposition veut pas d'un côté se plaint
d'avoir des godillots et de l'autre
d'avoir des percées sur le fond ils ont
raison et propositions il ya des trucs
très intéressant est ce que vous
préconisez vous par exemple ce qu'on lui
dit oui ce sont des bandits nettoyage
loi est particulièrement intéressant le
rêve revenu universel d'activité les
loyers ou regroupe toutes les aides le
rsa et toutes les aides qui vont te
permet une chose pour aller vite car on
doit aller un peu vite
ça permet de lutter contre un fléau qui
est un fléau qui concerne aussi les
associations qu'elles n'ont recours
aujourd'hui vous avez à peu près 30% des
aides sociales pour les plus précaires
qui ne sont juste pas demandé pour
diverses raisons principalement c'est
pas qu'on ya accès deuxièmement il y
aussi un sujet d'autocensure on va pas
demander l'aide on va pas chercher
l'aide à la caf ou va pas chercher une
aide supplémentaire parce que on veut
pas c'est admettre qu'on a un peu honte
ce qui se comprend aussi et donc ce
sujet du non recours on va parler des
jeunes je crois un moment en fait il ya
des multiples z un jeune une solution ça
va concerner les jeunes le revenu
d'activité non le r us est un plomb
internet une mesure intéressante elle
était d'ailleurs dans dont une des
propositions des manuels maquereau en
dérangeant
voilà un je trouve intéressant de le
remettre à l'ordre du jour parlementaire
été oubliée donc non il n'a pas été
oubliés on a eu deux trois petits soucis
entre temps ça n'a échappé à personne où
l'on empêche pas l'autre donné vous
dites ça allait faire cinq projets de
loi d'urgence sanitaire aurait pu être
dedans et un agenda
oui alors je vais avant tout genre
turrel structurels non mais j'adore
votre question conjoncturelle
structurelle on ne peut pas tout régler
on est face à une crise on fait du
conjoncturel je crois pas ça c'est une
réponse structurelle
le rsa c'est une réponse de fond ça
mérite qu'on s'intéresse
on se plaint souvent et les oppositions
que j'adore 10 soit on n'y a pas d'étude
d'impact pas ça mérite déjà d'avoir une
étude d'impact sur le virus mais c'est
une des quinze la position je trouve
particulièrement intéressant un mot sur
les jeunes beaux et vous parliez des
jeunes à l'instant de plus en plus
doivent aller aux restos du coeur parce
qu'ils peuvent pas manger il sent pas
suffisamment d'argent ils doivent aussi
ils doivent aussi aller dans les eaux et
dans les banques alimentaires ou au
secours populaire pour pour se vêtir
est ce que les associations qui te sont
déjà un peu débordé peuvent supporter
toute la misère du monde selon vous et
tout le poids de la crise en tout cas
tout le poids de la crise actuelle est
ce que c'est à elle finalement déçu mais
ça alors il ya trois questions et je
dois je penser la même c'est la même
alors déjà je pense pas que les
associations supporter toute la misère
du monde je pense que le gouvernement
est aux côtés des jeunes je pense que ce
soit la garantie jeune que soi les repas
au crous qu'on a doublé en euros que ce
soit l'ensemble des aides qu'on apporte
aujourd'hui on va en reparler dans
quelques instants
pardon mais ce sont pas y'a pas que les
associations qui oeuvrent dans ce moment
extrêmement difficile pour nos jeunes et
le gouvernement
je vais pas parler de milliards ça ne
parle à personne mais on peut pas dire
que dans le plan de relance on soit pas
à la hauteur et d'ailleurs je vous dis
un truc les chiffres le démontrent plus
d'un million de jeunes embauchés en fin
d'année dernière un million deux cent
mille jeunes en cdd
j'ai aussi ouais mais pardon voulais
qu'on voie le mauvais côté du vert moi
je vous parle du fait qu'on a aussi
embauché plus de jeunes que l'an passé
deuxièmement les associations en vrai
c'est des centaines de millions d'euros
de soutien je vais pas tous les détails
et parce qu'on n'a pas le temps dans la
relance dans la relance mais c'est aussi
des dizaines de millions d'euros dans
l'urgence et je vais être très clair
parce que j'ai des garanties
s'il faut faire plus dans les jours qui
viennent qu'il faut aligner 50 millions
de plus dans les jours qui viennent et
c'est le gouvernement prenne ministre
bruno le maire
je sais qu'on le fera clarion c'est pas
un chiffre donné par hasard si j'avais
tout le monde voici d'accord anne
hidalgo elle l a proposé une aide
exceptionnelle et temporaire de 500
euros pour les jeunes justement je sais
par expérience que peu d'emprise
est ce que c'est c'est 50 millions dont
vous nous parler il pourrait par exemple
être consacré à sa une aide pour les
jeunes est temporaire qui serait pas du
tout le rs1 mais écoutez 490 euros par
mois pour deux cent mille jeunes on a
doublé la garantie jeunes cinq cent
mille jeunes on a embarqué en
apprentissage depuis la guerre anti
jeunes c'est pour les plus précaires il
y en a aussi qui mendient
acte i vous avez bossé deux ans vous
êtes en rupture de charge vous avez plus
de boulot et pour les étudiants pour
ceux qui sont entre les deux justement
mais il ya aujourd'hui un jeune une
solution pour chacun on a de quoi
accompagner vous répondiez à 100
millions d'euros dans les missions
locales au moment où je vous parle qui
vient du plan de relance moi ce que je
vois
avec tout le respect que j'ai pour elle
c'est que c'est pas un plan de relance
dont parle anne hidalgo dont j'aimerais
bien que c'est sûrement canton
qu'ancienne député de paris elle
s'occupe à un peu plus de paris que la
présidentielle c'est un plan de carrière
je comprends la polémique elle est aisé
à découvrir maintenant qu'elle se
concentre sur paris et qu'elle fasse
plutôt que de demander sans cesse au
gouvernement de faire plus qu elle
applique déjà ce qu'on fait voulu fêter
lui suggérer de faire ça à paris sous
entendus moi je lui suggère déjà elle a
fait d une sortie très intéressante il
lui faut que le gouvernement soit à nos
côtés jeu complètement d'accord je
prends un exemple un seul rénovation
thermique des bâtiments
quelques millions d'euros 2,4 millions
d'euros je crois de la mairie de paris
24 millions d'euros pour paris de la
part du gouvernement mais c'est normal
c'est la moindre des choses que le
gouvernement salam et qu'on nous fasse
pas croire qu'on n'est pas là c'est 1
milliards du plan de relance pour parler
quasiment pas parlé aussi des
conséquences de la réforme des apl qui
se font sentir en ce moment pour un
certain nombre de publics fragiles par
exemple des étudiants en contrat
professionnel des des jeunes actifs qui
sont dans des situations encore un petit
peu compliqué est ce que c'est le bon
moment et bien de faire cette réforme
qui à réduire les appels pour pas mal de
monde en ce moment en cette période de
crise en ce moment si difficile c'est
jamais le bon moment surtout pour une
réforme difficile mais désolé là encore
je veux bien qu'on voit encore une fois
que le ver gide et 5 euros d'apl en
moins si on peut parler aussi de tout ce
qu'on fait en plus ça peut être pas mal
la réforme d après elle une nouveau mode
de calcul des centaines d'euros en moins
pour certaines familles mais donc ça
peut être vraiment vraiment compliqué
pour disperser les centaines d'euros
avec grand plaisir trouver moelleux
il ya eu un cas médical de personnes qui
ont bien dit c'est quoi linverse on a
mis en place des réformes et on fait
quoi stoppe tout bon les réformes elles
sont en cours et il ya un accompagnement
du gouvernement conjoncturels comme
structurelle auprès des plus jeunes
je veux bien qu'à chaque fois on voit ce
qui fonctionne pas c'est un système de
fer entre 700 millions et 1,3 milliard
d'économies donc on sait bien c'est
celle des références disponibles réels
c'est compliqué il faut du courage et je
dis pas que c'est facile
brigitte oui on va parler des mutuelles
les tarifs des complémentaires vont
augmenter de 4% en 2021 c'est l'ufc que
choisir qui le dit et puis un autre
chiffre plus 2,6 pour cent en moyenne ça
c'est la mutualité française
or il ya eu un accord avec bruno le
maire et les responsables des mutuelles
pour gelé en fait c'est ses tarifs
est ce qu'elles vont être rappelés à
l'ordre ses mutuelles alors déjà soyons
précis
l'ufc que choisir a pointé 123 mutuelle
pour 600 contrats j'ai pas le chiffre
parce que je n'ai pas en tête mais je
crois qu'il ya plus de 6 il n'y a pas
que 600 contrats ces chiffres étaient
non c'est pas ça une stricte ce chiffre
est parcellaire
mais alors sur ces gens c est ce que ces
120 idée complémentaire est ce que ces
123 vont être rappelés à l'ordre
bref possiblement pour dire les choses
simplement d'abord je voudrais juste
finir une phrase donc un en suisse a
comme le lait sur le feu notamment
écoliers du soft parce que bruno le
maire est à la manoeuvre mais olivier
dussopt pts 6 il ya eu des engagements
pris financiers ne pas augmenter
vous avez d'ailleurs une divergence
entre les deux points six de la
mutualité française et les 4% annoncés
par l'ufc dont déjà quand on est à bercy
on essaye de savoir si plutôt 2.6.1 ou
quatre et vous ne savez pas pour
l'instant on est dessus et à partir du
moment où on aura une étude plus précise
d'ailleurs dans les jours qui viennent
au savon que ce soit d'ailleurs les
assureurs ou les mutuelles ou même les
banques d'ailleurs à qui on travaille
beaucoup à bercy on rechigne jamais à
prendre des engagements et jean pierre
lemaire les refera revenir si les choses
n'étaient pas claires dans les jours qui
viennent merci va enquêter sur ces 123
buts est averti et sur la balle comme on
dit on a entendu les engagements il faut
qu'ils souhaitent sur ses 123 mutuelle
pointé du doigt par yeux c'est que
choisit le regarde mais sous les airs
oui oui on 123 oui globalement on
regarde ce qui se passe en termes
pendant les dix ans 23% 6-3 sur 602
est-ce qu on pourrait même imaginer une
contribution supplémentaire en
1021 ça a déjà été le cas en 12 a pas
échappé que c'est 1,5 milliards qui ont
été ponctionnés en plf 2021 et la crise
continue l on demande dépenses à cause
du duc au vide est ce qu'on peut
imaginer une contribution en 2010 a
expliqué partie des sujets je trouve
médiatiquement très intéressant vous
voyez c'est la limite de l'exercice
je peux pas répondre en une minute à la
passe qu'il ya derrière des ratios
prudentiels très casse pieds bâle iii
par exemple que doivent aussi respecter
ce savoir est ce qu'il y aura une
initiation à la question ça regardez
déjà compensé l'an passé sur le mail
address continue en 2021
bah on verra en blf en fin d'année way
pour l'instant ce n'est pas encore
totale une dernière question oui une
dernière question sur les plates formes
de livraison à domicile 1 comme hubert
il délivre ou etc
elles ont été présentées on te rappelles
quand elles ont été créées comme des
économies collaborative aujourd'hui on
voit bien qu'elles sont avant tout
synonyme de précarité
est ce que pour vous il ne serait pas
temps de réguler vraiment ce secteur
c'est un vrai sujet en tout cas réglés
l'emploi sur ces plateformes est un vrai
sujet il ya une mission parlementaire on
vous la fait un parlementaire pardon
ancien président de la cour de cassation
mes cheveux froid qui a remis un rapport
un deuxième rapport a été commandé par
elisabeth bornes ya quelques semaines
pour ma part au plan personnel c'est un
plan un sujet que je trouve
particulièrement urgent il je pense que
ça fera partie des sujets sur lequel on
va proposer des choses dans les mois qui
viennent aujourd'hui je pense notamment
aux jeunes qui travaillent dans ces
plateformes je pense beaucoup à l'emploi
ils n'ont pas de forcément de garanties
sociales n'ont pas de mutuelles sont pas
forcément accompagné vous voyez là
l'économie sociale et solidaire peut
apporter des réponses
il ya par exemple notamment à paris un
modèle intéressant qui s'appelle les cae
coopérative d'activités et d'emploi qui
permettrait qui par exemple de protéger
un peu plus les collaborateurs et donc
on pourrait envisager de réfléchir à ce
que les plateformes met en place des
coopératives d'activités et d'emploi
pour que les travailleurs des plates
formes et notamment les jeunes soient
moins précaire dans leur emploi en les
obligeant à le faire ça se discute
j'oblige rien avant d'avoir posé une
proposition en proposition claire la wii
mais comme en fait comme l était pas si
clair en termes de statut elle a suffi
d'une deuxième mission c'est ce que je
vous ai dit
première mission rendue deuxième mission
commandée par elisabeth bornes c'est un
sujet donc j'ai pas mais c'est une piste
qu en tout cas c'est un sujet sur lequel
il va falloir qu'on avance ça c'est
géant merci brigitte étape lundi
prochain évidemment le froid est annoncé
sur une bonne partie de la france cette
semaine le nord et le pas de calais ont
déjà déclenché plan grand froid
notamment pour mobiliser les moyens pour
mettre à l'abri les sdf est ce concept
période de kovy des associations sont
confrontées à un manque de bénévoles
alors là où vous avez raison c'est qu'on
a eu un problème générationnel et ce
depuis quelques mois c'est à dire que
c'est souvent des personnes retraitées
et qui donnent de leur temps aux autres
et donc oui on appuie on a pu parfois
manqué de bras notamment des
traditionnels bénévoles qui sont nos
aînés mais comme quoi il ya aussi des
bonnes nouvelles dans d'autres pays on a
aussi vu arriver des jeunes par le biais
par exemple du service suivi par le
biais des engagements citoyens qui
aujourd'hui je pense à la banque
alimentaire j'étais accompagné de trois
jeunes qui avaient moins de 25 ans là où
l'année dernière puisque j'ai été aussi
en tant que député j'avais des seniors
donc on a manqué un peu de gloire
nouvelle génération ce qui fait que
l'accompagnement on accueille maintenant
yves thréard et nettoyer c'est directeur
adjoint du figaro bonsoir yves soir
francis vous allez droit de boire un
coup en attendant ah oui il va vous
alors bien un homme actuellement qui
répète régulièrement qu'il veut un
scrutin proportionnel
je vois à aux législatives j'ai cité
évidemment françois bayrou dans une
interview au figaro il hier au grand
jury lci le figaro et rtl
est ce que vous êtes pour la
proportionnelle
moi je suis élu député
c'est un sujet qui concerne notre
représentation nationale
je suis très raccord et je sais que j'ai
pas vous étonner avec ce qu'a dit le
président de la république et qui
d'ailleurs a été largement commentée je
pense que c'est une initiative
parlementaire c'est une chute libre qui
doit être portée aussi par le parlement
la conférence des présidents par exemple
de juger de l'opa de l'inscrire ou pas à
l'agenda parlementaire
je comprends aussi parfois certaines
réticences de mes collègues ministres
dans une période
nous entraînons j'aurais nuit on est au
feu et je suis pas sûre entre nous que
même si c'est un débat fondamental pour
notre démocrate et vous êtes vous contre
moi je pense que ça c'est un sujet qui
pourrait être regardé d'un point de vue
personnel je trouve que ça ferait pas de
mal à la santé démocratique
ça fait pas de mal à la santé
démocratique en plus c'est simple c'est
une moi ouais mais une simple loi
perriand pour savoir que c'est pas parce
que c'est semble qu'il faut y aller un
parfois c'est super compliqué je voyais
aller quand même
il ya un risque oui en baisse ils ont
tenu oui oui où on vous en veux après
oui vous en vrai que ce soit sur les
marchés quand j'étais député ou dans les
quartiers nord à marseille où j'étais
jeudi vendredi
j'ai pas une personne qui m'ait arrêté
sur la proportionnelle par contre je me
suis fait arrêter sur d'autres sujets
sur notre jeunesse sur les âges les
personnes âgées sur le lac c'est votre
portefeuille ministériel
hocini paca packer mais la
proportionnelle je pense que c'est
intéressant pour répondre à une partie
de l'aide des chances si politique après
sacré total intégrale ou partielle
une petite dose comme on aux premiers
municipal par exemple autres comme un
exemple
d'accord j'ai lu un excellent article de
c'est un confrère qui s'appelle
l'opinion où on vous prête et bien
certaines fonctions auprès du premier
ministre comme quoi vous pourriez être
son porte parole
tacite d'une certaine façon et que vous
le conseiller beaucoup c'est vrai alors
ça je démens mais je démontre avec force
moi je m'auto conseil c'est déjà du
boulot il n'est pas besoin de mes
conseils
en revanche oui j'échange avec le
premier ministre souvent mais c'est
écrit dans le même papier qui est bien
source et et de votre confrère de
l'opinion que je suis loin d'être la
seule ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que d'abord il n'ya pas de différence de
d1 en d2 c'est pas parce que vous êtes
dans la d2 secrétaire d'état que vous ne
parlez pas au près et mini c'est
important de le faire savoir
deuxièmement il ya aussi écrit dans ce
métier parce que j'ai eu avec attention
qu'on est plusieurs à être à ses côtés
d'ailleurs on peut même dire l'ensemble
du gouvernement je crois et qu'en tout
cas on a voulu essayer de l'aider plus
et que de lui même il enfin le soutenir
plus et que de lui même il à hilard
chimie en disant nous et ça traduit bien
le l'homme voir le bonhomme qu'est jean
castex
ils nous traitent tous mais c'est vrai
que c'est important de souligner qu'ils
parlent aussi au petit secrétaire d'état
qui sont 38e sur 41 vous fait pas mal de
voir que finalement il est assez peu
apprécié parce que il fait le job
un sale job parce par celle de jean part
ça le temps et que contrairement à au
précédent premier ministre il n'a pas la
même cote de popularité
je suis prête à parier tout l'or du
monde oui pour le connaître un peu c'est
pas de ma faute
il s'avère qu'il ya 25 ans j'ai eu la
chance de travailler un peu avec lui
avant gré je pense que vraiment quand
ils se lèvent le matin ils s'en fichent
de ça je pense que c'est un grand
patriote et je pense que c'est un grand
commis d'état
ouais au sens de la république c'est à
dire que c'est un homme qui j'aurai nuit
bosse pour le pays dans une période où
vous l'avez dit qui est terrible et je
pense vraiment que c'est le cadet de ses
soucis sa cote de popularité mais
d'ailleurs on va pas se mentir on a
beaucoup refait le match avec edouard
philippe
on a beaucoup dit c'est le prémunit ce
que toute la majorité adore et star et
vous le savez on a un peu refait le
match en réalité edouard philippe les
six premiers mois ça a été super dur
notamment avec les députés de là
j'aurais été il ya un peu cette épreuve
de vérité dépendra alors vous avez dit
que vous aviez travaillé avec jean
castex et quelques années il y avait un
troisième une troisième personnalité qui
travaillent avec vous ses alliés
bertrand oui il semblerait que meilleur
qu'on travaillait pour lui voilà xavier
bertrand mais il a aussi des grandes
ambitions il a une ambition
présidentielle qui s'affirme de plus en
plus vous le voyez comme un trouble fête
du match qui est annoncée qui est le
match retour de 2017
entre van damme le pen et monsieur
macron trouble-fête je sais pas c'est un
peu tôt pour le dire alors de qualité ça
c'était c'est un homme de qualité c'est
c'était et sa demeure en m2 qualités et
j'ai dans mes traditions de ne jamais
craché sur mon passé en tout cas les
gens à qui j'ai bossé
donc c'est un homme de qualité qui fait
son bonhomme de chemin qui est un
président de région qui fait un certain
nombre de choses
pour autant je pense qu'on est un peu
loin du match si vous voulez et la
deuxième chose c'est que je pense que
les français ont carrément tête tout
sauf ça je sais pas si je me trompe mais
je pense que l'urgence dans la tête des
français pour beaucoup c'est ce que je
vais avoir un job ou sortir de la crise
est-ce que mon gamin comment ça pourrait
être un bon président de la république
au spa moyens répondre sincèrement vous
croyez pas que cette élection
présidentielle elle va se jouer sur la
gestion à saly à forte à parier en
partie oui mais aussi on le fera on va
tout faire recours mais je suis surtout
ce qui a été fait pendant ce quinquennat
et dont je ferai partie de celles qui
n'auront pas est ce que vous croyez pas
que justement cette les sanitaires va
avoir tout effacer et que finalement on
voit que le président de la république
fait du en même temps c'est à dire que
il pousse bien sûr des textes régalien
de séparatisme le bobo de la sécurité la
sécurité globale et de l'autre côté bien
ce dont vous avez parlé tout avec mes
consoeurs c'est à dire des textes plutôt
sociaux
pour les jeunes technique jusque là
c'est assez équilibré pour un vin qui
marchait que sur une jambe broyée il
marcherait de lever 10 pour un mec un
mec c'est un homme c'est d'accord dont
tellement entendu ça si oui oui a avoué
leur revient sur les deux jambes droit
de jouer sur les deux jambes il ya pas
plus de droite que de gauche
il marche parfaitement sur ses deux
jambes et ils vous convient alors que
vous venez de la droite alors j'aimerais
bien qu'avant ce quinquennat on ne
ressorte mon appartenance à la droite
trouvait moi ma carte d'adhésion aux
républicains ou à l'ump en or 10 ans
c'est à dire en vous étiez au bon
endroit par exemple jean castex avec qui
vous avez travaillé
vous êtes trop de qualités pour je
laisse passer désolé quand on travaille
en cabinet on a aussi un droit de
réserve
vous n'êtes pas forcément encartés bon
enfin vous n'êtes pas d'accord moi j'ai
travaillé avec des gens me disent qu'ils
sont pas forcément gardés en marché par
exemple sont pas forcément particulier
oui j'ai des techniciens c'est super
important c'est d'être convoqué le
conseiller concert voyez quitté au
cabinet de xavier bertrand qui est un
grand homme qui ne travaille plus je
crois mais qui était un grand monsieur
du cancer daniel nizri et ben il a fait
les plans cancer de jacques chirac il a
continué à travailler avec xavier
bertrand je crois même qu'il a continué
avec roselyne bachelot et qu'il était
encore expert son mari seul tour elle
importe les appartenances politiques la
direction de yves il ya normalement des
élections régionales au mois de juin
vous énormément monté de paris en
ile-de-france ministre il était question
qui est monsieur blanc caire qui soit
tête de liste finalement il n'y va pas
est ce à dire que c'est bien la majorité
présidentielle va se ranger derrière la
présidente sortant pendant pécresse il
vous a pas échappé
d'abord que je prie député de paris mais
je vais quand même répondre deuxièmement
entier
on a un candidat je prends un jeune
homme assez brillant qui a fait ses
preuves à l'assemblée qui est un
transilien qui n'est pas courage mais
qu'est ce qu'on s'en jeter j'ai
travaillé c'est pas très grave
vous allez l'élection autrement que par
la notoriété et laurent saint martin est
un candidat redoutable est remarquable
et gare à celui qui parient sur le fait
qu'il n'ait pas autant connu que les
deux autres je peux vous dire il est
redoutable
est-ce que vous allez vous engager dans
cette part également aux côtés de
laurent saint martin qui est quelqu'un
que j'appréciais infiniment oui mais je
suis 200% à mon poste à bercy
surtout dans la crise donc je ne serai
pas à chiché tout comme tous les
ministres c'est pour ça qu'on me pose
pas la question de savoir si vous serez
candidate à leurs origines
c'est toujours la même réponse merci
elle a dit je suis désolé a dit vous
avez annoncé le déblocage d'un fonds
d'urgence de 30 millions pour venir en
aide au secteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui permettra aux kings
associations de passer la crise
trois questions précises première chose
à quelques critères devront elles
répondent pour avoir droit à une partie
cet argent le premier des critères quand
elles vont s'inscrire en ligne sur
urgence tirait le ss point fr c'est
d'abord priorité à celles qui n'ont rien
reçu ces repas de fonds de solidarité
pas de prêts garanties d'état la
priorité est d'abord à celles qui n'ont
pas été aidés ensuite celles qui ont été
aidées mais pas suffisamment à l'aune de
leurs besoins pourront aussi être aidé
alors combien
d'après vous ça concernerait
d'associations alors y en a plus d'un
million en france d'associations oui
même si enfin vous avez 180 mille
associations employeuses c'est important
parce qu'elle sélectionne que des
bénévoles et celles qui ont des salariés
jean vous ciblez plutôt celle qui son
employeuse
en fait c'est pas possible c'est j'ai la
charge à bercy ou alors pas loin de
celle ci sans emploi ils ont ça veut pas
dire que je m'adresse ongs et
associations pour rubina et 30 mai
l'association en danger de mort
on a quelques milliers d'associations
déjà qu'ils ont mis la clé sous la porte
est donc cette aide a vocation à
accompagner à peu près dix mille
associations et lorsque parce que j'en
doute pas on aura écluses et ses 30
millions
s'il faut plus on ira chercher plus et
vous disiez tout à l'heure que
l'économie sociale et solidaire ça
concerne plein de secteurs à vous les
avez évoqué tout à l'heure est ce que
vous ne craignez pas des catastrophes à
venir comme peut-être dans
dans le domaine j'allais dire
économiques traditionnels céline et
qu'on a mis à part entière donc vous
avez raison des catastrophes
le mot est fort mais oui en tout cas des
fermetures ça on le craint et d'ailleurs
on a déjà quelques pertes d'emplois mais
je vois aussi que c'est une économie à
part et je vois aussi beaucoup d'acteurs
qui tirent leur épingle du jeu qui ont
le statut d'économie sociale et
solidaire ou qui pratiquent l'économie
sociale et ce statut protecteur vous
diriez dans le contexte actuel où c'est
ce statut est pas nécessairement
protecteur il est peut-être moderne il
peut être inspirant mais il n'est pas
plus protecteur en revanche il est
intéressant par rapport à ce qu'ils
engagent dans le partage du pouvoir avec
les salariés dans le partage de la
valeur
mais j'aurais donné un exemple quand
vous regardez c'est un de vos confrères
qu'il l'a fait le palmarès de la
croissance
vous avez des entreprises d'économie
sociale et solidaire vous avez des
acteurs qui ont tiré leur épingle du jeu
qui sont aujourd'hui dans le top 20 des
plus grosse croissance française dont
vingt deux jours en général on va
maintenant accueillir les deux
parlementaires qui vont débattre avec
vous ce soir
[Musique]
bonfort jean françois husson et régis
juanico
merci d'être sur ce perso ce soir jean
françois husson vous êtes sénateur et
l'air de meurthe et moselle et régis
juanico vous êtes le député génération
est ce le mouvement de benoît hamon l'un
de vos prédécesseurs au ministère de la
loire apparenté au parti socialiste
pour commencer la première question mais
ce sera vous jean françois husson vous
voulez parlez vous justement du système
coopératif et mutualiste parce que ça
représente du monde elle ça représente
du monde madame la ministre le sait bien
c'est plus de 2 millions de salariés ces
12 millions de bénévoles
c'est aussi 10 % de la création de
richesse de la mini jeux vous entendu
expliqué que le gouvernement mettait à
milliards 3 mai dans le plan de relance
mais dans le plan de relance il vous a
pas échappé que il ya plus de 100
milliards d'euros qui sont mis sur la
table et j'ai envie de dire
de mon point de vue le compte n'y est
pas vraiment parce que 1% par rapport à
un secteur qui effectivement
représentent des valeurs qui aujourd'hui
à mon avis sont en écho aux
préoccupations de nos concitoyens jeunes
ou moins jeunes mais les jeunes
notamment et qu'est ce qu'ils demandent
aujourd'hui ils veulent redonner du sens
à leur vie
ils sont prêts à s'engager dans ces 12
millions de bénévoles et on le voit dans
ce temps de crise et jeunes se
mobilisent
moi j'ai le sentiment aujourd'hui et
d'ailleurs vous le voyez à la fois par
les difficultés des jeunes étudiants
mais pas seulement
il ya aujourd'hui dans toutes les
générations qui sont en attente qui se
pose beaucoup de questions et qui
finalement regarde un peu la mire les
camps goisses il vous faut donc
aujourd'hui réagir vite et notamment à
l'endroit des jeunes quelles que soient
leurs origines et leurs territoires de
vie alors laquelle est la question sinon
et savamment il veut débattre avec vous
est ce que est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec ce qui est assez claire des jeunes
alors non mais ce cas il ya 1 % 1
milliard 3 sur son meilleur je vais déjà
répondre dans un premier temps et puis
après je doute pas de façon qu on va
reparler de notre jeunesse
c'est vrai que ce ratio on peut me
l'opposé moi ce que je vois c'est que
il n'y avait pas d'économie sociale et
solidaire au sein du gouvernement en
termes de portage politique et à bercy
je pense et je suis pas la seule en vrai
tout l'écosystème le reconnaît c'est
plutôt pas mal pour l'économie sociale
et solidaire d'ailleurs d'être revenue
là où elle était à l'époque de benoît
hamon c'est à dire puisque c'était une
économie à part entière qu'elle soit à
bercy deuxièmement vous avez raison
sénateurs us ont il ya 1,3 milliard
d'euros dans le plan de relance
directement fléché économie sociale et
solidaire et vous connaissez assez bien
des finances puisque vous y opérer au
sénat ces sont des sommes qui sont
fléchés vers l'économie sociale et
solidaire en dur et vous savez aussi
bien que moi que l'économie sociale et
solidaire lé interministériel donc il y
a des budgets d'économie sociale et
solidaire dans l'ensemble des ministères
je prends un exemple un milliard 3 vous
avez 600 millions d'euros avec madame
bornes sur l'insertion par l'activité
économique sur l'emploi dans le ss avec
les parcours emploi compétences
notamment sur le dispositif sésame que
vous connaissez sur les sports vous avez
aussi et j'y arrive
vous avez aussi des investissements
indirects pour quasiment 3 milliards
d'euros je pense notamment à tous qu'on
propose sur les 400 millions d'économie
circulaire 350 millions exactement
vous avez des chantiers qu'on mène aussi
par exemple avec julien dedans manger
sur les l'agroécologie on investit pour
pouvoir permettre à des coopérative
maraîchère de pouvoir mettre en place
des nouvelles lignes de production donc
ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il y à 1,3
milliard en direct un peu plus de 3
milliards en plus ce qui nous amène à 5
milliards et je vous dirai pour terminer
pardonnez moi juste j'ai répondre qu'est
je veux bien entendre que c'est pas
assez
moi ce que je dis aux acteurs de
l'économie de la musique sonne rc je
voulais dire finalement c'est que
également vous avez une forme
d'émiettement là où vous avez deux
bassistes est ce que vous proposez pour
les familles jusqu'à l'est partout alors
mes genoux que moi je pense que je vous
invite je nous invite à travailler
autrement et l'idée s'est pas démis y
était et c'est quand je vous dit par
exemple qu'il ya plus de 2000 ans harry
mais surtout qu'à 12 millions de
bénévoles qu'est ce que vous faites est
aujourd'hui ces bénévoles ils sont comme
les maires ils sont comme les élus
locaux à c e qui pour une part les élus
locaux à 90% sont des bénévoles aussi et
bien cela aujourd'hui ils tiennent une
partie de l'afrique
abou droit et donc en proximité le don
qu'il faut à ce qui se vend aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je ne suis pas un
aujourd'hui j'ai interrogé le ministre
oui mais j'aime bien avoir votre point
qu'aujourd'hui j'avais le point de vue
madame la ministre
c'est d'attirer votre attention sur ces
préoccupations en disant vous devez
absolument évite réorienter l'économie
notamment autour de ces valeurs qui sont
des valeurs humaines fortes dont la
france a besoin mais moi en famille et
et c'est ce que dit mais là où je
comprends pas c'est à dire quoi vous
mettez par exemple 6 milliards sur les
coopératives ou faites quoi vous faites
des fonds propres ou fait quoi que je
comprenne ce que c'est émietté mais moi
j'ai l'économie sociale et solidaire
dans le réemploi j'en ai dans
l'insertion par l'activité économique
j'en ai c'est pour ça que je voudrais
comprendre je sais que vous avez
d'ailleurs plus d'expérience que moi en
matière budgétaire donc vous dites que
c'est amy était j'ai une économie
sociale et solidaire qui
interministériel y en a parlé ce qu'il
faut comprendre c'est pas les idées
l'idée c'est pas de faire une bataille
de chiffres l'idée c'est de donner de
redonner confiance au pays et de
l'entraîner dans le redressement
et pour ça il faut aujourd'hui changer
le 6 le logiciel des valeurs notamment
sur ce sujet pour le gouvernement
changer le logiciel
j'entends bien que vous m'interrogez en
tant que ministre mais ça veut dire quoi
changer le logiciel des valeurs sert
plus de partage de la valeur plus de
gouvernail vous étiez dans le projet de
loi pacte je n'ai plus je les prendrai
donc bien sûr et vous étiez sur d'autres
valeurs
mais voilà je vous dis simplement vous
auriez fait de plus par exemple que la
suppression du forfait social sur la
participation
c'est aujourd'hui je suis maintenant le
on est aujourd'hui on n'est pas sur le
sujet d'avant-hier on est sur le sujet
d'aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui je pense que vous vous
trompez bien sûr vous vous trompez sur
un certain j'attendais mon jeu
j'ai aussi vos trolls le rôle c'est pas
de faire si vous voulez aller résiste
nico qui est à côté de vous été en
partie d'accord avec vous visiblement si
je voyais votre regard mais voulait
revenir vous sur le rsa absolument et
plus
pas seulement parce que madame grégoire
vous êtes ministre de l'économie sociale
et solidaire est par définition
vous êtes là ministre de l'innovation
sociale de l'expérimentation on évoquait
tout à l'heure les coopératives
d'activités et d'emploi que nous avions
voté j'étais rapporteur la commission
des finances à l'époque de la loi avance
sur le ss à l'époque et un statut
protecteur pour ce qu'on appelle et les
forçats du goudron les livreurs
aujourd'hui mais qu'est-ce qu'il ne
serait pas temps au vu aujourd'hui la
situation très dégradée de la jeunesse
dans notre pays
d'expérimenter une solution alors
peut-être temporaire de revenu universel
aujourd'hui tout simplement parce que ce
qui est dramatique dans ce pays c'est le
sort réservé aujourd'hui un autre
jeunesse et la transition vers l'âge
adulte qui maintenant depuis 40 ans
c'est pas nouveau
mettez une succession de cinq à dix ans
de petits boulots de peu de contrats
précaires et que vous aujourd'hui on
voit bien on l'a beaucoup travaillé avec
marie george buffet ces derniers mois
ici à l'assemblée nationale avec la
commission d' enquête sur les effets
l'accueil vide sur la jeunesse on a une
dégradation de l'état physique de
plusieurs générations
une dégradation de l'état psychologique
on a beaucoup parlé ces dernières
semaines mais aussi de leur situation
financière puisque 50% des étudiants
visuels de petits boulots et 40 % l'ont
perdue donc lisons ils sont tombés dans
la grande précarité
est ce qu'on ne devrait pas au delà
simplement de l'élargissement du rsa
mettre en place une expérimentation d'un
revenu universel pour la jeunesse au
moins quand dans cette période de crise
que vous disiez tout à fait pense qu'il
eût rsa
jeune et sans vous étonner c'est vrai
que j'en ai pas sur les lumignons sera
pas d'accord c'est moi c'est pas vous le
voyez bien d'ailleurs on peut nous le
reprocher pour le coup un jeune une
solution ça veut pas dire la même
solution pour tous les jeunes servir un
jeune une solution en fonction de son
parcours en fonction de son âge en
fonction de son diplôme de son
éloignement de son point de départ
l'égalité des chances plus ou moins aidé
au démarrage aujourd'hui on a une une
panoplie dead et d'ailleurs ça
fonctionne plutôt bien on voit que
l'apprentissage et je ne doute pas que
vous en réjouissez décolle enfin dans un
pays on voit qu'on a embauché 1,2
million de jeunes en fin d'année
dernière en cdd cdi
on voit que il ya des solutions pour
accompagner et dans tout ce qu'on fait
c'est accompagner vers la formation
raccompagnés vers la formation ou
accompagner vers l'emploi c'est vrai que
si jamais le rsa jeunes pour le coup
avait été la solution depuis des années
pardonnez-moi du point mais un je pense
que vous n'auriez peut-être porter avec
la précédente majorité je sais pas si
vous avez essayé de farine mais on m'a
fait la guerre anti jaune qui est
maintenant on est élargie et compulsif i
et qui est effectivement et vous
connaissez bien le sujet pour ibos et
depuis des années qui est sur un public
un public spécifique mais moi je crois
pas que ce soit avec un rsa jeunes qu'on
a l'ambition pour notre jeunesse parce
que c'est rsa jeunes
après c'est pas de formation c'est pas
de job crs à jeudi coût revenu universel
encore autre chose
ces garanties mais il y avait les deux
ans dans la question est maintenant du
coup je vous donne le deuxième sur le
revenu universel d'activité je les dis
toute activité revenu universel oui
parce que la fusion des aides
insuffisant le problème c'est ces cinq à
dix ans pour aller vers un emploi
durable
aujourd'hui qu'on impose
c'est compter avec attention ce que vous
disiez il ya quelques temps dans une
tribune sur facebook là dessus je ya des
idées qui s'en rapproche ya le 'capital
jeunes ont peut-être en parle et qui est
pas très loin du niveau de jeunesse oui
on va j'ai pas de sectarisme a priori il
ya effectivement un sujet qui et comment
on embarque cette jeunesse vous avez
raison il faut des années 5 à 10 ans
vous vous dites mais ça va plusieurs
années pour trouver un emploi
je pense que ça fait partie des sujets
qui sont intéressants et et à ouvrir
mais pour ce qui est du rsa jeunes c'est
pour ma part je crois pas que ce soit
l'ambition pour moi pour la jeunesse
auront toujours revenu universel donc
j'entends bien ce soir que c'est un
sujet qui peut vous intéresser un sujet
qui est dans l'air du temps c'est un
sujet d'ailleurs qu'une partie des
membres de la majorité regarde ici
intéressés ça me paraît être la moindre
des choses et après ça veut pas dire que
j adore madame la ministre en lien avec
le jeu que vient de traiter moi je
voudrais appeler votre attention sur une
préoccupation au delà des satisfecit que
vous décerner en tous les cas l'action
du gouvernement sur l'apprentissage est
un centre de formation il ya des bons
résultats je le dis moi je suis frappé
par contre des dysfonctionnements du
mans que kiel des dysfonctionnements qui
existe entre la formation et les emplois
non pourvus
aujourd'hui dans les entreprises il ya
un nombre impressionnant dans des
domaines divers de services de
logistique dans des chais des grands
opérateurs d'énergie aujourd'hui vous
avez un grand nombre d'offres qui ne
sont pas satisfaites
il ya donc un souci entre la formation
initiale les formations qualifiantes
ça veut dire qu'il ya une perte de
finalement de compétences et d'argent
par le fonctionnement la formation
initiale qui doivent aujourd'hui être
compensées souvent par des formations
faites par les entreprises elles-mêmes
avec des conventions avec l'état avec
les régions est ce que aujourd'hui vous
ne pensez pas qu'il faut améliorer
dispositif pour faire en sorte dans le
slogan un emploi une solution qui est
une formation qui donne une
qualification avec la possibilité d'être
pleinement opérationnel dans la vie
active
vous pointez
vraiment un sujet absolument majeur et
on a encore des progrès à faire
soyons clairs ça fait longtemps ça ça
fait bien quelques dizaines d'années
qu'on a ce problème d'adéquation de
l'offre et de la demande d'emploi il me
semble en tous les cas qu'il est
aujourd'hui plus exempt jamais moi je
crois pardonnez moi je sais qu'on est
responsable de tous les maux mais je
pense que ça fait longtemps qu importe
les origines politiques c'est pas le
sujet mais qu'on a ce sujet d'adéquation
entre l'offre et la demande chez nos
jeunes et pour permettre à nos jeunes de
trouver des boulots pardon il n'y a pas
que les jeunes j'ai pas évolué les
jeunes c'est bien ça le drame
pardonnez-moi pardonner mal légère
inattention d'un quart de seconde ce
n'est pas dans mes habitudes
alors on reprend oui vous avez raison je
suis simplement très simplement je pense
qu'il ya c'est un sujet majeur
on y travaille le ce que fait
aujourd'hui le gouvernement notamment
dans le plan de relance alors j'ai
entendu qu'il était trop morcelé et ses
armées c'est aussi d'orienter avec le
pic d'orienter et c'est ce qu'on essaie
de faire depuis un moment les formations
vers les lieux de demandes d'emploi les
bassins d'emploi les plus importants je
pense aussi qui a peut-être ici plus de
liberté plus d'initiative a donné
peut-être aux régions sur ce sujet
région qui ont la compétence économique
et entre nous qui sont souvent les plus
éclairés sur leur bassin d'emploi ça
c'est logique
ah je vous attends mais pour tout vous
dire pour le vivre dans la région de
rente est oui c'est exactement ce qui se
passe mais il ya juste l'initiative
aujourd'hui c'est à mon avis c'est trop
souvent la région qui doit aller
chercher proposé faire du sur mesure
or aujourd'hui quand vous êtes sur un
espace de cinq millions et demi
d'habitants vous ne pouvez pas faire
quasiment du sur mesure à chaque fois et
ça c'est un sujet enfin je voulais vous
dire vous parlez des bassins d'emploi
les bassins d'emploi ne sont pas
qu'urbain et aujourd'hui dans les
inégalités notamment sociale et d'accès
à l'emploi
la question des mobilités et donc pour
les personnes issues des territoires
excentré éloignés des villes est un des
premiers facteurs d'inégalités
vous le savez aussi on y travaille sans
parler du fait qu'on ait légiféré dessus
qu'on a mis beaucoup d'argent dans le
plan de relance pour améliorer ça que
les régions d'ailleurs et les acteurs
des collectivités locales sont pas en
reste avec les forfaits mobilité aussi
déployé au plan local
moi je crois qu'il ya aussi une chose
qui est très importante parce qu'on
parle d'aujourd'hui hic et nunc
moi ce qui me questionnent et ce qui
m'interroge beaucoup et bruno le maire
pour le coup ici c'est comment on forme
aussi nos jeunes et nos moins jeunes aux
emplois d'aujourd'hui mais surtout aux
emplois qui arrive demain même pas après
demain demain et ça c'est un sacré défi
janicot oui je voulais aborder la vie
associative et et nos bénévoles puisque
vous avez abordé tout salon le fonds
d'urgence mais pour les associations
employeuses les 200000 employeuse 90%
aujourd'hui des associations repose
uniquement sur en fait l'engagement de
leurs bénévoles
or ces associations là c'est un coup
d'arrêt depuis un an à part pour les
associations de solidarité
heureusement un quai lesquels viennent
en aide aux plus démunis et pour le
sport pour la culture nous sommes
extrêmement inquiets puisque aujourd'hui
dans nos communes dans nos territoires
il n'y a plus aucune manifestation
associative et sportive etc
or aujourd'hui ces associations là elles
ont une perte de ressources financières
très importantes plus de 20 à 30% et ses
pertes la sont pas par définition qu'on
pensait qu'est ce qu'elles peuvent
attendre aujourd'hui notamment en terme
d'engagement des bénévoles parce qu'on
risque aussi de perdre les bénévoles
dont beaucoup sont des seniors qui
aujourd'hui hésitent à revenir par
crainte et c'est normal et par
précaution aussi sanitaire et donc on a
vraiment cette inquiétude vraiment sur
la vie associative
qu'est ce qu'elles peuvent prétendre
aujourd'hui pour repartir même si ça
sera très chaotique et qu'elles peuvent
attendre
alors j'ai pu je vais répondre même si
je déjà modestement j'essaie de faire ma
ma part et seraient que j'ai j'ai en
charge de m'occuper des associations
employeuses donc c'est vrai mais je sais
que
là dessus on est raccord tous les trois
qu'il était indispensable qu'on les aide
à minima avec ce fonds de 30 millions et
qu'on fasse plus si nécessaire voulais
mentionner régis juanico et mercy a
effectivement 200 millions d'euros pour
les associations
hébergement d'urgence et solidarité et
c'est pas ça arrive c'est que les appels
à projets sont sortis les premiers 50
millions d'euros sont en train d'être
pourvus et vous savez qu'on en fait au
plus vite et et vous avez relève
aliments père aussi oui sûr mais je veux
pas être trop longue mais oui et ça a
des caisses d'ailleurs sait pas on va
décaisser c'est à dire que c'est en
cours le deuxième appel à projets pour
les associations arrive dans quelques
jours et ce ministère de la santé qu'il
le soit il y a aussi une approche
sectorielle et la ministre des sports a
annoncé il ya quelques semaines 15
millions d'euros d'être direct aux
associations et pour le coup ça c'est
plutôt à destination des associations
bénévoles pour les accompagner je pense
que vous allez me dire je pense que vous
allez me dire que ça n'est pas assez
mais qu'il faut faire plus donc à quoi
peuvent prétendre ces associations déjà
est-ce que vous est ce que le fonds de
d'urgence de 15 millions d'euros
sectorielle
de votre expérience d'élus locaux
puisque vous êtes aussi des élus du
territoire est ce que ça arrive je pense
que c'est en train d'arriver
est-ce qu'il faut plus est-ce que vous
avez plus de demandes que
qu'effectivement de montants financiers
disponibles et ben il faut il faut que
la ministre des sports de monde plus
d'argent à l'endroit des associations
sportives ou vous parliez au
gouvernement on se parle et on se parle
souvent et je les soutiens dans sa
demande et je sais qu'elle n'aura pas
froid aux yeux pour aller en demander
plus et qu'on va faire ce qu'il faut
elle se bat comme roselyne bachelot sur
la culture d'ailleurs c'est le parallèle
associations culturelles et associations
sportives est malheureusement assez fort
puisqu'elles sont toutes les deux
empêcher donc il y à des fonds
sectoriels en plus de l'aide d'urgence
et du plan de relance
et s'il faut faire plus je pense qu on
essaiera de faire plus le risque c'est
la perte de lien social et c'est
beaucoup des grandes et vous avez
beaucoup
enfin pourquoi raison pardon c'est
totalement raison parle beaucoup des
grandes associations
aujourd'hui mon inquiétude et c'est pour
ça que j'ai j'ai circonscrit à 10
salariés maximum
c'est vraiment les petites et là où vous
avez raison c'est que celles qui sont le
plus en risque et ce sont celles qu'on
doit aider majoritairement parce que là
les petites
il faut passer fa par les fédérations
parce que les bénévoles les structures
sont puisqu'elles sont par nature bien
sûr ils sont débordés c'est comme les
petites communes ces intrigues mais la
bonne à tout faire
ce sont des gens qui font bien mais ce
sont des gens qui parfois d'abord ont
moins de temps puis nombreux la
structure administrative des gens qui
savent pas forcément il ya aussi le
formation et où le non recours c'est un
favori des comptes ces chiffres datent
de
il ya quelques jours donc je les partage
avec vous on a moins d'un pour cent du
fonds de solidarité 13 milliards
décaissés qui est allé aux associations
ça fait 200 millions d'euros
à chaque fois que je vais faire un
plateau pardonnez moi à chaque fois que
je faire un plateau on ai dit quoi on
dit holmes elle va encore parler du
fonds de 30 millions d'euros elle en a
déjà parlé mais je vais vous dire à
chaque fois que je vais faire un plateau
je vais en parler et j'hésite même à me
faire un t-shirt pour en parler c'est
l'hiver mais cc c'est pas parce que
c'est pas une annonce que c'est pas
important
j'ai plein de plateau pas vous je le dis
qu'il me dit oui mais là on a déjà parlé
mais de grâce on a des dizaines de
milliers l'association a sauvé donc on
va en parler à chaque fois et je risque
d'être très obsessionnel avec le même
genre à faire un détour maintenant par
le filaire all eyes on nous attend il
demande en quelques jours où nous attend
le rédacteur en chef du figaro live un
sens au bon soir vincent qu'est-ce que
vous raison du côté de vos lecteurs de
vos internautes et nos téléspectateurs
bonsoir olivier grégoire bien ce qu'on a
vu en tous les cas parmi les sujets qui
sont très commentée aujourd'hui c'est
cette volonté du maire rassemblement
national de perpignan louis aliot de
rouvrir à quatre musées de sa ville en
respectant les consignes sanitaires
estimant que la culture est un bien
essentiel quel est votre point de vue
roux et j'allais loire mon premier
réflexe et j'avais même commencé la
phrase donc c'est c'est un bien
essentiel surtout en période
préélectorale je pense je pense que
c'est pas trés c'est pas très
sérieux je pense que c'est une position
qui lui appartient qui est un peu mais
pas forcément très collective au nom de
celles et ceux qui ne peuvent pas
réouvrir on a d'ailleurs eu ce genre de
d'initiative ya quelques mois je me
souviens de débats à la rentrée où
certains maires avaient pris des
initiatives je crois que on est un peu
tous dans le même bateau et que ce n'est
pas très responsable sané mon point de
vue et je le partage ajoute pour autant
qu'eux ils pointent ici un sujet qui est
un crève coeur pour nous tous sur la vie
culturelle sur les musées sur l'ensemble
des cinémas moi m'ont nommé dans la
culture c'est tous les jours et puis
bientôt un an que c'est très difficile
mais je crois pas que les français
souhaitent jupe et je pense que ça n'est
pas très républicain comme attitude
voilà vraiment un mot oui juste est ce
que vous pensez qu'on peut continuer
longtemps à avoir cette situation où les
musées reste fermé voilà où auraient
convenu de précariser tout une tous les
secteurs vous savez comme moi que
l'objectif n'est
évidemment pas celui que vous venez de
citer j'écoutais encore roselyne
bachelot ce matin ce qu'il nous faut
c'est un tout petit peu de visibilité
c'est à dire si tenté puisque c'est tous
les jours qu'on se pose la question à la
culture qu'on puisse réouvrir qu'on
puisse avoir plus que plus de 3 4 jours
de visibilité ce qui est un peu le cas
aujourd'hui j'ajoute et pardonnez moi
mais j'ai entendu beaucoup notamment de
d'artistes cité des situations en europe
du sud je vais pas polémiquer dont je
vois aujourd'hui l'ampleur des dégâts je
pense à un pays en particulier
je sais que c'est dur je sais que c'est
compliqué le portugal oh mais
aujourd'hui c'est chaque jour qu'on se
pose la question et vous voyez je suis
comme vous je n'espère qu'une seule
chose c'est que la prochaine fois on
puisse se parler des musées quirico et
que vous connaissez tous les mâts et des
théâtres et des clubs et les
discothèques et de toute notre vie qu
merci vincent merci jean françois husson
merci régis juanico allez merci olivier
dégardin verte y participer aux lions à
audition publique qui revient lundi à
19h30 bonne soirée
[Musique]